she and your most recent project is
Alyssa portrait of a teen killer is that
the current name or has there been a
change that's what was it it's actually
been a few changes originally i called
it Columbine even though it's not about
you know Columbine and then we were
shooting it i called it the coal mine
then I decided after we're finished
shooting the call to call mine effect
because basically this actually goes
into a story i forgot about when I heard
about Alyssa it was getting it reminded
me of calm I I stopped watching TV
basically when call might happen because
there was some trailer for a show about
like I'm one-hour special incall mind I
saw where it had the platoon music you
know that music from the two million
women to foes like dying he throws his
arms out you know a very great cinematic
moment in music but they used that music
with the real footage of the kids
running out screaming while their
friends are you know getting shot to
death and I just thought that that was
so sickening and evil to like use real
footage of these kids being you know
shot to death as like a cinematic moment
to get ratings you know and so I stopped
watching TV as a teenager when I saw
that I just was like I'm done like it
right there i just stopped watching TV
and just stuck to a going to the theater
or dvds you know and no more television
shows because i want to see a trailer
like I just literally stopped watching
TV shows everything and when I heard
about Alyssa the way listen Bustamante
the way that they were glamorizing what
happened like it was a show it was
specifically my love cuz i don't know
because i tend to customer yeah yeah i
was in the season two really offensive
but actually i was like what an evil you
know i just was so disgusted by
the what I saw you know what she was
saying you know about Alyssa because I
was thinking this is a real person you
don't even know she you know you just
found out about it you don't even know
she did it yet she confessed but that
could mean anything because she's a kid
I know based on being a kid myself that
police will try and beat you into a
false confession you know and so I was
just the kind of press it was getting I
just I was so reminded of Columbine I
did you know it just seemed so sickening
to sensationalize this stuff with kids
and use it for ratings and so because i
was reminded of Columbine I guess it was
more of a me title you know didn't make
sense anybody in necessarily but me so I
called it the call might affect but then
people thought i was using the titles to
sensationalize the film so kind of like
you know bad clashed on me and it wasn't
about Columbine some people thought I
was just trying to use the call my name
to sell its I was like this exact
opposite of what I was trying to do so i
changed it to my name is a by anonymous
we were trying to think of a title I
think I came up with my name is a and
then Alicia the producer mentioned
something about a book called ask alice
oh yeah yeah I'm rented but something
about it being anonymous or by anonymous
or some pain and I'm like you know my
name is a by anonymous because i like
having titles were when you google it
only the movie comes up like amateur
porn circular you know that was the only
that had never been used before you know
that name and so my name is a I you know
googled it and I liked it's a gazillion
links to any time somebody saying my
name is a something it would come up so
I'm like how can we have this be only
the movies so we added the by anonymous
part and I thought it kind of fit the
ambiguity that a word ambiguity yeah
biggest nature vocabulary actually isn't
great um I thought that kind of just fit
um because the film is kind of very it
doesn't really follow this up fall as a
few characters and you're not really
sure of exactly what's going on so I
thought I kind of thought the anonymous
thing kind of fit how I'm you know with
my name is a you know by anonymous so
anyway so we did that and then the film
circulated for so many years because it
was such a hard sell and we finally
found a distributor and then the
distributor you know it took a while to
get everything ready and fair
to market it and then finally just
recently after you know it's been like
almost five years since we shot the
movie now then all of a sudden there was
a name change because the DVD is still
called my name is a by anonymous but the
internet crowd who has a short attention
span doesn't like to think or have any
kind of you know meaning in anything
we're like okay we have to have a title
that's going to grab you right off the
bat and it needs to start this is what I
was told it needs to start with like a
number or a letter a B or C because
people are too lazy when they're
watching when they're looking for a good
movie which don't even get me started on
that but our generation the new
generation of you know the internet
crowd is just too lazy to want to have
any kind of you know substance in
anything you know I was told so we need
to hit you something with like that's
like in your face and starts with like a
narb and since her name was Alisa that
actually worked out you know it all
worked out and I actually like the title
but that's the title for anything that's
not the DVD basically to answer that one
question uh her that long answer and
that question is a my name is a by
anonymous is DVD Alyssa a portrait of a
teen killer is everything else so
pay-per-view TV digital cable i don't
know i only watch dvds so all these
other outlets you know however people
watch movies these days that's going to
have the alyssa title
controversy over the film let's talk
about why there's controversy yeah and I
feel like to actually be more
controversy with that new title because
now it's kind of spelling out exactly
what it is and what's the comp the
controversy is um it has I think when
people see if there's going to be new
controversy to there's a lot of child
actors which this isn't even the
controversy now this will probably be
more once people watch it so we have
like all these eight ten year old kids
you know at the lead to girls or 13 and
14 or 13 or 14 at the time now that now
everyone's like 18 is it took so long to
come out but um at the time the two
League rows of 13 and 14 years old and
then we have like a boy was accelerate
and then the nine year old victim the is
a ten-year-old you know actress so we
have all this kind of violent attitude I
guess towards children and tons of you
know cussing and lots of kind of
bullying but it's done in such a
realistic way or kind of looks like it's
really happening which it wasn't you
know if you look you know between takes
everyone's just laughing I mean the lead
actor some little boy Roxy brother and
sister you know and the moms were like
there the whole time supervising
everything we had a professional acting
coach was there the entire time you know
watching everything but when you're
watching it you don't know all that and
when you're watching it there's just a
lot of oakville Garrity towards children
so that's what I going to create a whole
new kind of controversy I'm thinking but
what's going on right now is the fact
that it was big you know based on the
murder of a real nine year old and a
very vicious one and one that is one of
the most popular murder cases in recent
memory and so a lot of people trying to
think of a way to explain it it's ok for
the news to be like hey this just
happened let's talk about it everybody
watch the news and give us ratings so we
can all you know get money and and and
sensationalize this but it's not okay
what I've learned is when an independent
filmmaker says okay instead of spending
five minutes on this topic and making
money I'm going to spend five years
trying to
stand it so for me there's no
controversy whatsoever for me it's I'm
the one actually trying to do what the
news i think is glamorizing or
sensationalizing i want to understand
why this happens but unfortunately the
public they look at it as oh this guy is
making money this guy is just looking
for you know so I and an easy thing to
make a film about so I guess that that's
the controversy if that's even kind of
answering the question is um people
don't people it's okay for the news the
sensationalized murder but people don't
want to see a film made about it and I
actually don't understand i guess i
could try to understand why people are
mad about that but i actually don't
because she basically made fun of alyssa
for trying to kill herself once she was
arrested she tried to kill herself by
scratching her arms open if their nails
which i think is a very painful way to
die and i don't think she was doing it
for attention because the girl already
with this on Prozac and known have all
these mental issues and Hardy had
already tried to kill herself and had
self-inflicted wounds that you could see
from the pictures that were using all
over her arm and and was known not to
make that public to like her friends you
know and stuff like that and so anyway
this was making fun of this 15 year old
who we don't even know if she actually
did it you know or why she did it she
was making fun of this girl for trying
to kill herself and I thought that was
the most sickening thing I'd ever seen
is for the news to make fun of a kid
trying to kill himself like what the
and to me that was I guess contour
you know I mean if anything is
controversial I don't understand
basically why it wasn't that because
that outraged me so much that that's
what made me go okay I want to make a
film about that because it reminded me
of the coal mine thing you know she's
making all this money and
sensationalized seeing this murder of
this child and making fun of this other
child and she's probably a millionaire
I'm assuming you know because of it and
it's totally okay and I had to me that
that just sickens me I want to
understand you know something more than
that you know I want to understand why
this stuff happens and
but apparently that's the person who is
controversial so so Shane why show this
story if it is depressing why spend five
years plus of your life delving into it
I understand you know that that judgment
of some people that are designated as
you know sort of the pundits able to
talk about it and not be judged whereas
those that are artists are more you know
trashed or brought down in some way
branded as evil because they want to
show light about something but what was
it about this story that you felt you
needed to explore and spend so much time
and energy and money and resources on um
I guess to just jump into it basically
when I saw the picture of Alyssa the
most famous one it was her like you know
just kind of make this claw you know
like she had all this you know weird bad
makeup on but she was making like this
you know cloth figure at the camera and
on her arm she had a like 50 really bad
self like really just deep scarred
self-inflicted wounds on her arm and I
don't know if you can see but I have
exactly just that um so I basically felt
like I was looking into a mirror
suddenly I was ass like holy I mean
mine aren't has visible anymore because
they're a lot older than the hers were
probably you know no but I just was like
that's I mean there I they were so
identical it was just like you know I
mean it was just like that's exactly
what my arm looks like and that's kind
of trippy and being a self abuser I
already know that that I can't
understand or even picture or fathom
somebody self abuses killing somebody
else didn't make sense to me if anything
she would kill herself which she already
tried to do and so I kind of felt I
guess I felt like I was looking into a
mirror in a way and I do know at one
point right before i started self
abusing when i was 13 i had thought of
killing kids at my school because I was
bullied bullied so bad and I literally
had when I was in eighth grade I
literally had
not a single friend like not even the
dorks would be my friend and um you know
and because it was a it was
predominantly a Hispanic school so I got
picked on for being white you know I
wasn't allowed to use the bathroom I
would get like people put gum in my hair
and they'd have to cut my hair out you
know to get the gum out and you know
just smack me over the head with weapons
you know just for like no reason
whatsoever other than walking you know
or trying to the bathroom and anyways
that was so bad I was terrified to go to
school and so I actually mapped out how
I was gonna kill everybody at my school
but then I was like I don't have guns so
I was like okay so i armed myself with
kitchen knives because that's the only
weapon I could get and but then what
actually so many things it's kind of
hard to pinpoint one I ended up seeing
blood all over the walls one day at
school like this but like we went on for
like maybe 15 20 feet his blood on the
walls and it was one of the guys who I
wanted to up and he was a big guy
and somebody still I don't know who beat
his ass but somebody beat him up really
bad this big guy who I couldn't stand it
would pick on me and it was a bunch of
people picked on me but he was one of
them and it actually don't know not only
frighten me seen his blood it's made me
sad and I think that's when I realized I
could never hurt somebody else and I
could never especially with a knife so
that kind of raises I guess maybe the
gun control issue if I had a gun maybe
would be a lot easier just point and
shoot but there's no way I could have
walked up to somebody and stabbed them I
mean I feel bad if I have to kill a fly
I rather just go away you know and so um
that's when I decided I couldn't ever
hurt anybody and then I started self
abusing and I thought that that would
maybe make people afraid of me because I
started by like grinding my hands into
the walls till I had no skin on my
knuckles so I thought maybe they would
think I beat somebody up or that's kind
of how it started you know the 13 year
old my 13 old mentality and then it
started leading them the other stuff and
I didn't even up actually cutting until
I was 26 so it was like 13 years later
when it turned into I guess direct you
know
how would you say it I you know I mean
like it was always other forms of
self-abuse it wasn't the cutting thing I
totally forgot the question because I
told you I call around in circles but it
was uh that's what made me once so you
saw yes picture and you saw her arm and
there was something in her I saw myself
in her that's what it was um and I guess
it was in need to understand that or
could I kill somebody I'm looking in
America I've killed somebody or why did
she do it there's all these things going
through my head it was a need to
understand it um it was outraged by just
a media in general but mainly her i just
i was so sickened by that lady it's just
and I know she does it for show and who
knows she maybe she's even a nice person
but but still she's selling out if she
is I mean that's just awful what she
does I think and so they I combined with
you know making me think about Columbine
why I start I think a lot of things are
going on reminding me of the coal mine
thing and that's what actually made me
stop watching television and yet you
know I'm a filmmaker but I stopped
watching you know television which is
like a huge I think part of the industry
and so I just had so many things
floating through my head you know I I
guess I was angry at the media that was
another thing to it so there's so many
things a few months earlier I tried to
make a movie about human trafficking and
that was an issue I've been it was in
2009 I attempted to make a start started
to get together an idea for human
trafficking and I've been wanting to do
it since 2005 when I first had heard
about like sex trafficking and so it
would have been about you know sex
trafficking in particular and I'd been
spending months trying to figure out the
story i could make and then this girl
ended up in the news Jaycee Dugard who
most people have probably heard about if
they've you know ever wanted to make a
movie about human trafficking might have
heard about this girl she lived for 18
years as a slave to the sky and had kids
and then she ended up being found you
know they thought she was dead for
almost two
and they founder and she was like in
2009 she was like the most famous I
guess person in the world as far as
non-celebrity I would say I mean this he
was just everywhere and so when I heard
the story I was like oh I want to make a
movie like that and i announced it
thinking you know nobody's gonna you
know i announced it to like a couple
hindi horror sites thinking nobody's
going to read this i just can use this
to maybe get a few actors i want you
know and i said i got the idea from the
jaycee dugard thing and because i made a
movie called amateur porn star killer
next thing i know it is posting a
pornographer making Jaycee Dugard porno
and i'm like like seriously and and
then for about 48 hours i became the
most hated man in the world i mean my
friends were like hey you're on the news
in ireland you're on the news in korea
their korean newspapers or writing about
you you know england you're Oliver
England you're on the front page of the
globe tabloids I'm like I had no idea
the world worked this way like the media
like you know like i said in 1999 i
stopped watching the news or television
because the columbine but then in 2009
now decade later I almost killed myself
over that I mean because they like it
causes problems within my family because
I mean everybody my dad was calling me
up yeah you know you're on the radio
getting thrashed right now I mean God
that experience was just awful and I was
sincerely I mean I was trying to make
this film I thought was important and I
just said you know hey I got the idea
from this story so I want to make
basically her story but I was going to
change all the names all this stuff and
I just wanted to see what the Stockholm
Syndrome i was going to explore the
Stockholm Syndrome me know and I thought
that was really interesting and that was
always kind of something that I think I
explored subconsciously you know
throughout you know other you know some
of my other films and and then all of a
sudden know everyone in the world
decided to hate me and and I wasn't used
to being thrashed like any I interviewed
me and that guy was a nightmare just
completely I had no idea I didn't listen
stuff and that guy just um I was like
well the worst experiences of my life
talking to that guy you know I just like
almost like wanted to die after talking
to him you know and then these people
they the whole thing none of these
people gave a you know and that's
what happened so I dropped the movie I
ruined my relationship I mean it ruined
so many things for me and then literally
it was like that same time it was like
only a couple weeks before like Alyssa
you know had been all over the news so
this was all happening at the same time
I was all over the news for you know
trying to make this human trafficking
thing and then she was all over the news
and maybe that was it to maybe I saw all
these accusations people don't want to
wait for anything like they here Oh
so-and-so just got you know rate by are
you know five girls to Scott raped they
have a suspect his name is so-and-so oh
wait it's not him little retraction and
then that guy's life is wrong I mean
they don't give one damn about ruining
the media doesn't care about ruin
anybody's life you know they ruined
lives in my opinion the media ruins
lives left and right they don't care
they just want headlines they this one a
story and I think that was one thing
that made me want to jump on it because
I already felt like my life was ruined I
didn't I mean my life literally felt
ruined at that point and I feel like
I've been picking myself up ever since
now I feel finally back to being me
which is funny because I now that the
movies coming out I'm like should you
know I didn't now something else is
going to happen but I think that that
was a big thing is I felt like I'd
nothing to lose I feel like I had
nothing to lose at that point
everything's screwed you know right now
for me why don't I just go tackle this
subject on this I can't make a story
about a victim when I make a story about
a murderer who I almost think might be a
victim because I at least think she's a
victim of the media so maybe that's it
if that answers a question because and
then the thing with making it then I
started thinking section and do it sighs
all another story and now I'm actually
almost convinced you didn't even do the
murder and that actually made me think
about my childhood which was completely
ruined by false accusations and the
court in the system and all this stuff
so yeah maybe that answers the question
the media it was it was the man with
nothing to lose I guess is maybe Thea so
you say that because of this supposed
these accusations and how they just
labeled you a pornographer and that
you're trying to make this horrific film
and then it was spread everywhere and
you were painted a certain way and you
lost relationships and things fizzle for
you you wanted to take your own life but
you didn't what was the reason what
stopped you um that's a big question I
mean it's not like I wanted to tightest
felt like I could die you know and like
I don't think I've ever been like a
suicidal person but there's so many
times where I'm on the road and I'm like
maybe I'll just run off the cliff right
now I think I mean that happened so many
times you know and all it takes is that
one second read is say it and you
actually do it and I've never done it
obviously um I mean sometimes it's not
even like I feel like dying sometimes
it's like I feel so numb I'm in so much
pain that I've actually become numb that
I want to maybe crash my car into a pole
and hope that nothing bad happens it
just really hurts and it kind of wakes
me back up like okay now you're alive
wait you know wake up and get back to it
you know so I have those kind of I guess
feelings it's not like I've ever had oh
I'm going to put a gun to my head I'm
going to take lots of pills I've never
actually thought that way but it's been
more it's always driving is I Drive a
lot and so it's always been more like
I'm not you're really depress and I'm
always driving so it's lost times i'm on
the road and I'm just like a you know I
don't know but you you didn't do it I
never do yeah I mean times that this
happened and that's when you heard about
alyssa is it Bustamante yeah okay that's
when you heard about Alyssa Bustamante
so was that did you somehow become
obsessed with that sometimes there's
like something that'll break us out of
our own like troubles and we kind of
zero in on that whether it's like a
reality star and we're just focus you
know that's what most people do but but
you focused on this which I found
interesting because you saw some
parallels and you saw shoes being made
out to be a certain person and I really
don't know much about the case so I
can't
speak either way but you saw something
and you you focused on that so did that
making this film it took you out of your
you're probably yeah because I had been
made out to be a monster and then I saw
her being made out to be a monster and
then I saw a lot of you know
similarities you know of me and her and
then so yes I guess my you know it's
like kind of grabbed my attention off of
that and put on that but was interesting
you know it only took us four days to
shoot the film which was it was actually
the best most fun I've ever had shooting
a movie was so easy was like the easiest
shoot the world but then I had to sit on
the film we felt like in April but then
I got dumped in July and it was an
insanely bad breakup and then um that's
when I finally finally started editing
so I actually that's when I became
obsessed i think is after the break up
because that's when i actually started
putting the film together and then I
literally felt like I only had this film
I mean that that's what happened is a
you know I kind of made the movie it
took my attention off the the thing to
happen to me in the media and then I
went back to kind of life the
relationship issues and then a couple
months later then that was over and then
I that's when I was just like didn't
want to live and I kind of like became
something in depression with this movie
and then became obsessed with it i guess
but i don't think i became think I
became a completely obsessed until like
maybe you're after ike finished editing
and I and and I couldn't get the movie
out I think that's when I became
obsessed and that's when I started
reading more about the case I started
talking to people at her school you know
I went to school with her and that's why
I started thinking she didn't do it and
that's when I think I actually became
really obsessed because then I started
really kind of digging deep trying to
find out you know she did it and I think
I totally went off the question again
but um well you had mentioned in other
interviews that I read about you that
filmmaking saved your life so was this
the one time or were there other times
and also how did it save your life oh
yeah I guess it probably is my life
every time I make a movie me a little
bit you know okay um how's it saved
why not like when I when I made amateur
porn circular I mean that was just an
experiment that's been the biggest thing
I've ever made as far as hits you know
it was a movie I shot in three hours
with no script and 45 bucks you know it
was um I do it's always a but it's
always me with girls and it's a breakup
you know you know so I'm always
depressed over a girlfriend and then I
come up with something so like how much
porn star killer like when I did that I
had never made a feature I had attempted
multiple times since I was 10 to make a
feature and and I had shot three
features and I could just can never
finish them so in two thousand when I
was 24 after getting dumped by my first
long-term relationship there was this a
bad year in general and that was X to
the worst year was my grandma had died
and she was like basically my mom to me
like I have my mom but I mean my mom's
blinds my grandma did a lot of mom's
stuff so my grandma and my mom kinda
like they were like my two moms in a way
so my grandma died and basically was
like a big huge deal for me and then the
girl I grew up with next Dora got killed
by drunk driver like a few weeks before
she died and then um and then a few
months later than the girl I thought was
a spoon rest of my life with dummy and
so that was the first point I think
aside from all the times and when I was
a kid where I didn't wanted to die this
was the first time I think my adult life
I wanted to die but I was pissed off
because I hadn't completed a feature and
I'd spent he know thousands of dollars
and years you know on all these three no
three features since I was ten trying to
make a feature and I never had so I was
like we know what can I make you know
tonight and have it in the can and I was
you know I called up a friend I'm like
you know how about I play a co killer
and like I rape and kill you and yeah
but it's really graphic it hasn't been
really done you know before that I can
think of you know maybe once or twice
but thinking I was trying to think of
something that would maybe be very kind
of in-your-face and very confrontational
because probably it was taking my mind
away from stuff but also something i
could shoot very quickly and so that's
probably an example where it saved my
life because I didn't put my attention
to that and then that movie started
treating all this controversy something
I got kind of caught
than that and then when I made you know
out reports regular to I was in the
middle of a breakup from a girl who
tried to kill me multiple times and so I
think that was an escape from her you
know and then I made the third one that
was a try after I broke up for that girl
and then when I made my name is hey whoa
and I made my name is a I was fine it
but it took my way like I was currently
in a relationship but it take my mind
away from the the news stuff but then
editing my name is a saved me from
another break up you know and I don't
know you know I mean I like now like I
had another break up you know in October
but the girl didn't move out until just
this April and so it was tearing me up
this whole time said anything feel like
we broke up until April and so I've been
doing films now that I think I've been
saving my life from that like the past
two months I've never worked so much my
life and that was to you know because I
was feeling all suicidal again I guess
after her so I I guess every time I make
a movie you know is its kind of saving
my life rarely do I make a movie where
I'm like really happy and hey I'm making
a movie it's usually life sucks and this
movie is saving my life you know that
answers question usually I'm always in a
state of life sucks and and a movie
saves my life so maybe that's why maybe
that's why people get something out of
it cuz I'm always kind of pouring I
guess a lot of heart and soul into it
I'm never just doing it I'll never just
doing it to kill time you know it's it's
always to get my mind off of stuff you
know she's looking back at your life and
all the things that you went through
that that sound like they're pretty
painful and they would hurt most of the
population would you change your life or
would you say you know what maybe if I
had it too comfortable it wouldn't push
me to make these films because so many
people talk about doing this stuff and
they don't either do it or they don't
finish it
so you're finishing it you're even
taking five years to believe in
something which is pretty commendable so
would you change all that yeah yeah you
know I really don't know i mean there's
because there's so many things that
could be changed so it's like at what
point do you it's all I you know it's
like those time travel movies you know
what at what point i forget the term
that at what point do you you know like
say there's 30 different things
traumatic things that have happened you
start from the first one I think my
thing that the butterfly effect or some
reason like you know what point do you
make that splice you know because I mean
life a lot of these things I've had a
lot of these things happen works like
these big events I guess you know and
they started when I was five so it's
like at what point would i if I change
anything like at what point would I do
that I don't know you know I mean most
of my think most of what I make i think
is about like lost childhood or rape or
incest you know and I mean that goes
back to when I was five years old you
know somebody thought I was being
sexually abused because a picture I drew
and and then that put me in foster care
for two years you know and then my one
year old brother ended up you know
living at this foster family told his 18
so it was my only sibling inside I
really had a sibling and to this day I
still kind of feel responsible for that
and it to this day well he finally stuck
he's 30 now he finally stopped
questioning that when he was like 27 28
you know so it's only just recently
where he's stopped kind of getting in my
mom's face about why did you give me up
you know and
you know to my foster family and that
all dates back to something I did you
know because I do a picture that
grown-ups misinterpreted but um you know
my life's never been the same so it's
like what I you know it caused my family
to you know moves you know you know
counties it caused me to never have a
sibling you know and it gave my grandma
stroke you know the stress cuz she was
like 75 at the time and and even my
daddy was only 35 at the time and he
thought he was having a heart attack
turned out it was just gas like he was
so stressed he was like creating all
this you know gas that made him feel
like he was having a heart attack and it
just I'm in a date so many lives were
ruined from that so lots of times I
think what if I didn't just draw the
picture but I was five so it's
like you know I think like God my
imagination like you know I was even too
risque even back when I was a
five-year-old you know what's wrong with
me like I think about that sometimes too
like what's wrong with me why why would
I you know draw something what was what
was I thinking when I drew that you know
you know so I don't know at what point
would I take something back you know is
I think about that all the time so
obviously it haunts me but then again
who the hell knows where I'd be if none
of this stuff happened and I wouldn't
have all this anger towards you know
it's a not societal society but the
system to law enforcement like I have so
it's such a rebellious attitude towards
Authority and you know and it all
started with that you know and I mean
you know I don't know there's so many
things or it's like I was sort of taking
that back but maybe then this wouldn't
happen I mean or I wish I would you know
could take that back or I wish I never
would have said I was in to make that
human trafficking movie because then I
wouldn't have that whole reputation but
then that made me end up making the
Alyssa movie but then who knows how
that's going to be perceived so maybe I
shouldn't have made that you know I mean
there's so many things that have
happened where i'm like i don't know if
i would take I don't know it's a really
hard question
I don't know what drives me necessarily
because I've loved movies you know since
I was a little kid and I wanted my dream
was to make Van Damme movies you know to
star or direct you know star and or
drugs and a movies and that's nothing
like the movies I make I mean I'm so far
from making those kind of movies so
maybe it would have been better if that
something happened because maybe I'd be
making action movies and fun movies it's
not all these depressing I want to kill
myself kind of movies you know maybe
that doesn't help me maybe just makes me
kind of live in that misery I don't I
don't know you know I mean that's really
I don't really know how to answer that
would you push yourself to make them I
might I might have I mean I loved movie
I loved see now it's not even like I
love movies now it's like it's like I
have to do it which could be better but
it's like there's no that's not
necessarily enjoyment anymore you know
and I try to like go what it's like The
Expendables movies and get enjoyment
like that back and sometimes I do but I
am it's more like no I want to watch
something that depresses the out of
me is that healthy you know I don't know
so so you do sometimes wonder whether it
relates back to that picture at five
years old or other things if maybe
things were more Ozzie and Harriet and
and perfect sort of picket white fence
where would you be now but maybe you
wouldn't have that same drive inside you
to make these films because it's not
easy to make films and a lot of people
talk you know we already went down there
and I brought that up but have you
thought about that that may be all that
happened but it also pushed you to put
these stories out that maybe if stuff
was too easy you wouldn't have done
anything yeah I mean I definitely think
that that's the case but
but what I've been in a better place if
not that had happened I was making cool
action movies I guess is the thing you
know I mean it's like you know life's
short so like maybe would have been
better if I was just having fun making
movies and not so serious you know you
know maybe you'd be better if I was not
pushing myself because I had to but
pushing myself because I wanted to you
know I feel like I pushed myself because
I have to not because I want to her
because I'm having fun you know I mean I
am having fun here and you know there
but it's more like you know even looking
back at stuff i made like depresses me
because i think about the mindset i was
in you know I don't think about
necessarily the shot or you know you
know that the filmmaking aspect I think
more about the the mind set the mood the
emotion which is what I love though too
I mean on it's a really hard question
cuz like i want to feel emotional when I
watch something but like I said life is
short so maybe you'd be better
to just feel fun and bliss and you know
like often never never land when you're
making movies I don't it's a hard
question so why not feel like you get to
make these films so many people come to
LA so many people go to film school they
have access to the money for these
cameras but you get to do it a lot of
people talk about they don't do it why
do you get to do it it's not that I get
to do it it's just that I do it you know
on if they if they have like some people
I guess maybe what this day and age I
guess everybody can but i would say some
people third that poor maybe they can't
you know or their that busy like who
knows you know they have to take care of
somebody 24 hours a day who knows what
kind of problems somebody might have you
know or have to deal with in life but um
but if somebody has the equipment like
you said are the money something i get
to do it they get to do it to they're
just choosing not to do it you know I
choose to i don't really know anything
else
and it pisses me off a lot to like I
don't know how to make a living you know
I don't know how to like really take
care of myself all's I know is movies
you know and there's not really any
money in that you know at least for
indie filmmakers and definitely not
today unless you know unless you're
really maybe internet savvy and you know
how to work that area but I don't really
know technology that well I am all about
the emotional part and I'll have
somebody you know like a partner who's
like hey I'll work free and i'll figure
all that stuff out and we'll split the
sharer you know so I do it because I
have no idea what else to do you know I
wish lots of times I had a nine-to-five
job and I knew there was something where
I could get a nine-to-five job but I've
no I don't have any skills at anything
you know I even check into it regularly
like every month I'm like a this
I'm done and then I'll start
looking for jobs and I'm like oh I have
no degrees in anything the only thing i
could do is like flip burgers you know
and i want to do that so that's why I
keep doing that's why I get to do this
because I don't want to flip the burger
so I'll keep doing this and I don't have
time to suddenly go okay let me spend
six years getting a degree in this
because there are certain things I'd
like to do like and it's not in film you
know I'd like to work with like troubled
youth or like in a youth home or I got a
rape crisis center so like that whenever
I check on stuff like that it's like you
have to have this two-year degree or
this four-year degree which I think in a
way is going to dumb because it maybe
it'd be better if its people with
experience and that kind of stuff but um
you know so I I think about not doing it
all the time but I get to do it because
I don't really have an option i guess
it's how I look at it you know like what
else I'm gonna do I better make
another movie I don't know you know like
I feel like I might be homeless one day
because like nothing's you know paying
the bills or working out so I'm you know
if I can make 10 movies before that
happens maybe that'd be better because
maybe something will happen you know
like maybe somehow that'll lead to an
actual job or like I can then start you
know supporting myself
from filmmaking otherwise I'm kind of
screwed do you think a peer group holds
you back or helped you like as far as
suppose you have a big circle of friends
you know you talked about being more
alone when you were younger do you think
as you get into your adult years that's
really a bad thing in some ways because
sometimes if you mean like friends
within the industry already mean like
for like just friends period friends
period do you think sometimes that helps
what you think it holds you back because
you only you don't want to rise above
them you want to just stay where they
are and if maybe they are doing anything
you'll stay at that level but if they
are you'll want to go with them so that
makes sense does a peer group help you
rise or can it also hold you back I
think if you are like working together
but like I don't have like friends that
is hang out with them prima saloner you
know and then the people i do hang out
with their other people in the industry
and and what i think is important I was
actually think about this earlier so
it's funny to guest is um I think it's
good to grow a family I think it's one
reason it's been hard for me is because
I'm always out on my own you know and if
I work with people less time since this
new piece whoever is free at the moment
but I think if you had maybe 10 people
who all work together like look at the
mumblecore movement you know how they
all kind of you know like got big and
they all had you know kind of work you
know exchanged working on films together
or look at like James Franco and Seth
Rogen all you know they all you know say
oh they all got each other's back and
they're stronger that way you know and
you know even with the the coming back
of Stallone and all these people you
know like they all they all have each
other's back and unless you're like Tom
Cruise you know or like I was instead
Denzel Washington even him like do you
notice once him tony scott's are working
together it was like every movie almost
you know and I I think would be great to
have something like that because I think
kind of if you're if you're doing well
together you know just keep feeding off
of it and keep you know it's like you
know all the few of them you lift me up
it's like you're doing it by yourself
it's just um you know you just climb in
a ladder you get exhausted but if you
got you know friends carrying you okay
you're tired let me help you up in your
tire let me help you about Nina it's
like need a break and you know I mean
like I think that's what's important it
would be great to have friends within
the industry to create a family really I
think it's really good when you create a
family like I worked with this one actor
Kevin gauge and I've been talking with
like seven years but I just never had
gotten a chance to like do anything with
them or even meet up with him it was a
you know phone call and emails for seven
years and then finally we worked on
something together and he was just like
the best personal world to work with
he's always like a bad guy I can heat
and all these movies he's known for
being this is this horrendous kind of
sleazy sleazy bad guy on top of that but
he sits like just you feel so motivated
working with them and so like as soon as
I worked with him it was like I worked
on like five films with them and like a
six month period because I just wanted
to keep working with them and that
definitely made me want it because I
wanted to keep working with him that
made me want to keep working you know
and and it's like I would love to work
on anything he's working on because he's
just so awesome to be around and I think
if you have like 10 people like that
even if you just had a you know one
other person like that it's just I think
that that helps you know so hopefully
that a specific question it would be
great to have people like that i think
but in real life i don't really have
like I don't go after Adam it's hard for
me because I don't drink I don't do
drugs and I realize it actually creates
a lot of problems having a social life
because the idiom came up yesterday the
drinking thing comes up all the time
people don't know what to do with me cuz
I don't drink as if there's nothing else
to do in life or something I don't know
and so I just kind of I'm just kind of a
loner and I'm always working on movies
and so in my free time I'm either
watching movies or I just hang out the
dogs like I go to the gym you know so
I'm pretty much a loner
so you've been in this filmmaking game
for well over a decade because you said
you were making films even as young as
seven right because your dad was in the
industry what do you think the future of
filmmaking will be like 10 to 20 years
from now what do you see you know DVD
market obviously collapsed took a lot of
jobs with it and in 20 years 20 years
yeah I mean I just wonder what its gonna
be like in a year you know I mean I've
been talking to guys I work with you
know multiple distributors and I've been
talking to a lot of them recently about
stuff like this because they're you know
everyone's freaking out you know and um
I remember and i'm talking about indie
distributors i don't know as far as like
you know bigger indie like ifc or
magnolia i'm not talking about big indie
you know or the or Sony or anything I'm
talking about like the really indie
distributors i remember in 2007 one of
them told me that a good selling DVD was
3,000 copies you know if they sold three
thousand copies then they made their
money back and a little bit more now
it's 300 copies and and a lot of their
movies to like 50 to 100 copies it's
like I can't imagine you know we're
going to movie for a year and sells like
hundred copies I mean you get a 100
youtube views in a couple seconds you
know with the right video and you know
and then you know another company did
they're not going to do DVD anymore
they're like you know what we're just
gonna do strictly you know the internet
or cable which for somebody like me so I
don't even have the internet you know so
I basically watching movies I have no
idea how it's going to try because
watching movies for me in a small town
sucks because I only rented from the
video stores used to have ten now we
have none we only have red box and their
movies suck and you know yet like 30 you
know choice of like 30 films and he
can't even like look at the back of the
DVD so my whole way of viewing movies
has
gotten changed so much i would i would
run a movie based on the back of the DVD
because I really kind of would break or
sell the movie and when I would do that
ninety-five percent i would say of what
I rented turned out to be good because i
knew i had to judge that way now it's
the opposite ninety-five percent of why
i watch it's almost to the point really
want to watch movies anymore because i
don't really get them judge it before I
you know you know I base it the saw
little image from the front you know
when I ran and who knows how long red
box is going to be around if everything
goes to the internet you know so I don't
know I'm actually really freaked out
about that I mean it seems like people's
attention spans are too short you know
like it reminds me of some of these
futuristic movies where you're watching
you know they would show i'm trying to
think of what moving it was a minority
report I don't know what it was but um
maybe it was a gamer anyways I can't
remember the movie but I swear there's
been multiple movies were like they'll
show somebody watching 20 channels at
once you know 20 different team monitors
and that actually seems like what people
do nowadays it seems like they're close
to that so and and that means I don't
see how anybody is going to want to sit
through a movie anymore I mean I went
and saw Sin City last night and there
was four people in the theater that just
came out I saw expendables 3 on opening
night and there were six people in the
theater and Hollywood at the Dome you
know I mean I know there's certain
movies that are doing well but it's like
I was looking around the past few movies
I've been doing on Mike how are these
places going to keep in business you
know I mean I know there's money still
being made but it's like for how big how
much bigger the population is the money
has not gone up with it you know I mean
and that means a lot of people a large
percentage of people are not going to
the movies like they used to be and as
far as at home I mean you know people
start watching something I see a lot of
people review my stuff they're like oh I
watched 30 seconds I don't want to watch
it but I'm going to talk about it
anyways and that's the kind of people
that live in today's world they don't
everybody's sewn to themself I don't
think anybody wants to invest two hours
into a movie of something somebody else
did and for how self-centered people are
today I don't actually see movie is
existing in 20 years I don't see how it
actually could at the rate we're going
so who knows what the phone business is
going to be like in 20 years it's
probably gonna be 20 channels of look at
me or the news I mean who wants to spend
two hours invested in something that's
not them we're 60 look at me generation
you know and and nothing sells any more
people pirate movies like crazy they
don't think it's worth anything you know
a thousand people spend a hundred
million dollars over the course of three
years making a movie and people think
they can just rip it off you know I mean
so what does that say about word you
know the industry is going on I don't
know it's scary that's one reason why
I'm trying to pump out as many movies as
I can right now or work as much as I can
because I think that it could possibly
completely died I mean you know then
again the world could explode so who
knows see how that could happen tomorrow
so when you saw your dad in the industry
you would go with him right to he was an
editor he worked yeah I never really
actually understood yeah when his job
where he was an editor he did like lots
of stuff you know like when yeah I know
he they did laser discs you know back
there like d phase of this company and I
watched them go through so many
transitions because they like ladies of
disc was you know before DVD it was
around way before DVD and and they would
watch them do all they you know they had
caused when completed commentaries you
know so I met like you know like huh
like John Wayne's kids like all these
people since I was a little kid I was
hanging out with the crew namely Dougray
Charlie Chaplin's wife or one of his
ex-wives so I got a great kind of film
history lesson from the time I was
really young on what and that that's
what he would do he would just you know
he'd bring in a lot of these kind of
people and interview them or put in like
extras for like you know like interviews
with all these people basically all the
extra features for laser discs and then
I transitioned into DVD but I know
throughout that he did a lot of editing
editing as well I think yeah a couple
features i know it
the trailers and stuff like that so he
started bringing me and highs memory
first show me how to edit when I was
five by doing jump cuts to make somebody
just disappear he knows that's when I
first caught my attention like he showed
me how to disappear from a jump cut you
know like you know somebody's walking
just you know cut it to nobody's there
and as a five-year-old I was like what
you know and then when I was seven I
started editing from like BHS to be a
test clara hook it up and do it at home
but then when i was nine or ten he
started bringing me into image when he
start working to image he started be
bringing me there because he was working
at hollywood stars or something like
that for a TV show before that so there
I just hang out but then I guess he felt
I was old enough at nine or ten that he
surged show me how to actually edit on
the pro equipment they had you know
where he did all these kind of like tape
the table was really editing on film I'm
sure was even harder but this was
definitely harder than um you know all
the adobe and final cut stuff i mean he
really had to take your time doing all
this stuff and that's how I learned at
it for ten years I was editing there
until 2000 when I started then learning
how to do it on premiere at home you
know so from like 1992 2000 i think i
was editing all my stuff at image
basically you know on off hours I'd make
him going on the weekend cuz I can do it
while he's organ so you'd have to like
bring me in on the weekend so I was
always making I'm good he probably lived
at work there in those ten years because
i think im gonna weekend so i could edit
you know and he would just hang out and
do something else or catch up on work
you know what was it like to be around
that culture just of people that were
working on films passionate about them
do you see that same mindset today or
different world that seems like it's a
different quality in movies back then
there was more story based that's just
my opinion
you think yeah you know as a kid on my
register because I would oh man I would
talk to a lot of people there but I
usually if I wasn't you know if I was
editing I was by myself or with him and
then if i was there you know like after
school or something i'd just go in one
of the rooms it would actually have any
QC stuff like so my first experience i
think was entered to dragging it was
some Bruce Lee movie and and so I wrote
down literally every single scratch mark
and the you know which was constant you
know because I didn't realize that I was
checking for like digital you know
hiccups I was looking at all the scratch
marks from the actual film and marking
every single time code of all that but
anyways that's tough i would do is i
would like kind of you know i can be
like a loner off it's not like I had a
good understanding of um I guess how
people were with me I mean everybody was
friendly to me but it's like I don't
know I've always been a loner so it's I
just watched how it changed from the
latest to the DVD and then and then then
they spent you know the last couple
years he was there they just started
laying people off little by little and
finally he was the last group of people
to go you know before they just finally
had sold out to somebody else you know
because they're still around but it's
not the same company really and they're
doing now they're doing all these big
movies actually but um or you know big
star kind of driven movies but I think
it's actually all done like out you know
they don't do it in-house anymore they
just have their company that acquires it
and everybody else does all that you
know it was a huge company they had a
couple hundred people or maybe several
hundred people work in there so I've
watched all the transitioning of that I
had more experience I guess watching
that the transition of this company
because I spent 20 years kind of yeah I
said why have 20 years of knowledge of I
guys I guess of how image worked you
know going from major laserdisc to not
some hate your DVD to trying to build
back up to major theatrical but then
tiny company and I kind of watched all
that happen so I kind of got it I guess
yeah I mean I never really thought about
that but I got a good knowledge of that
more than I guess
the kind of people more like I got a
understanding of how a certain company
went through two decades I guess so i'm
paraphrasing a bit but i think you've
been quoted as saying you'd rather be
polarizing than having people just have
like this lukewarm reaction like yeah
Shane Ryan's those films are okay but
you'd rather have somebody really feel
strongly one way or the other why is
that love your films or it's not for
them yeah cuz I mean if you just think
something's alright then you forget
about it you know I mean there's been
movies were I don't know if like I hated
them but I would never watch them again
like does one movie I saw called family
portraits i see i said i'ma just put it
out actually i saw like 10 years ago and
I didn't hate it i just i hated watching
it you know it was sort of it disturbed
me this really struck a nerve and I was
just like I instantly gave the movie
away to somebody else who I thought
might want to watch it i was like i
don't need it back you know I'm never
gonna watch this movie again but you got
to watch it you know versus those other
movies words like that was amazing and I
have to keep watching it but there was
another movie again I didn't hate it
it's called them the living and the dead
I couldn't even get through it it just
it really just did not make me feel good
and and I've seen plenty movies that
don't make me feel good or kind of
disturbed me but this just I don't know
I explain it it just really pissed me
off um but I still went out and bought
just last week this is years later you
know they're like a new movie that I saw
by him because I'm like okay I gotta try
and watch this now because like I
thought he did such a good job with what
he's doing but um my stone was so loud
enough that I thought he did you know a
really good job with the way he's doing
it's just did not sit well with me and
that's what a lot of people have told me
but I rather my movie not sit well with
you then you just be like I was cool
because do I ever talk about movies that
I was like I was alright I probably
forgot about it
you don't really want that as an artist
for a lot of reasons if somebody
absolutely loves or hates I specifically
love it obviously you want the love
thing first but they absolutely hate it
they're going to talk about it that's
free publicity so you and I've had to
learn to look at filmmaking from every
angle doing everything much you know on
my own you know for so many years it's
like I mean even you know distributing
like I've gotten in with distributors
learning that whole thing so I really
kind of learned I don't really know how
to do anything well but I know a little
bit about everything you know and so I'm
always looking at stuff from every angle
and if they hate it they're going to
talk about it and then they're going to
create discussion and debate I love
debate I actually went to college when I
tried to go to college when i was 18 i
went for journalism and i never liked
going to school so like we had a I never
did good and quizzes every quiz I failed
I think I got an F on every single quiz
but we were only graded two ways the
other way we were graded was um we would
have to read these debates on you know
this versus that and then bright our
opinion on why we were so for something
or so against something and I didn't
read a single one of these debates I
just read the subject and I just bs'd
the whole thing and I never got lower
than a plus because I even got an extra
credit on some at a plus plus extra
credit you know and what that was that I
just loved that idea of having such a
strong opinion I didn't even need to
know it was about I just could just find
something and tune in and just go with
it you know and I think if people so
that doesn't hold the baiting thing so I
think if people have that just like all
these things we were told to read like
it just creates all that awareness you
know because it creates the base like I
saw some filmmaker the disgaea know Ryan
Nicholson who makes very gory films and
my films don't have any gore or they are
all kind of psychological or there or
they have explicit nudity you know there
driven through like boy ism but they're
not gory so Ryan has a different crowd
but we but he's a co-producer on my name
is a so anyways he really loved the
amateur porn star killer movies which
don't have a single drop of blood in the
whole trilogy and so he was promoting
those yet the other day on his facebook
and people to start going often about
how much they hated it because his fans
probably all wanted to see gore and then
they get a single drop of blood you know
and but that just created him now
defending it you know filmmaker whose
you know more well known in me you know
now defending me so just created this
kind of debate thing and why he liked it
you know I mean so like it just it
creates discussion he creates talk raise
awareness but on top of people hating it
because I didn't like it then there's
people who hate it because they don't
want to face it and that's I think more
what i like is i think because of my
background everything that's happened
it's like I've had to deal with
since I was five years old that know
five-year-olds would have to deal with
that I've had to face like every day of
my life since and I had to face so much
as a kid I never felt like I got to
be a kid and so it's like I'm kind of
throwing out all my anger on screen and
you can't even deal with that if
I had to deal with this in real life you
better deal with it on screen you know I
mean it's like I guess this is that
confrontational attitude you know it's
like if somebody was raped and then they
made a movie about rape and somebody's
like oh I can't deal with that it's like
I'm you know like it like of a girl you
know made a movie about it you know rape
it's like how dares almost like how you
know dares somebody like no you better
face this this stuff happens it happened
to me what's this person get raped and
know that this happens you know and I
think that's what I do is you know it's
like this stuff happened to me or I'm
very aware of it and you don't want to
deal with it know you better you know
you better learn that that's out there
just face it you know
I don't know if that makes sense but
it's just kind of like I mean p I
because I think if people are more aware
maybe it won't happen as much or maybe
people would be more if people who have
a heart at least would be more willing
to stop it you know I just think I guess
it's an awareness thing if people isn't
like my movies going to change the world
it's not like I make a movie thing is
going to change the world but you change
people one person at a time I think and
if you make people go hey this happens
you just made me realize that maybe from
there something in start you know for
sometimes people don't like stuff
because it reminds them of themselves
like people that they say oh I can't
stand that person well times you look at
them and they're very similar I don't
see it but it's so sometimes people
don't want to see stuff about themselves
thats dark well it's funny because
that's exactly what happened with
amateur porn star killer and our friend
a chatty mentioned there's documentary
about it now and this guy we know Chad
it was one of the very first people to
stand he was one of like the first three
people there's like three guys who had
who saw the movie they're all like
middle-aged guys who saw it and just
really stood behind it and and she had
specifically had said that it made him
question not only himself but society
you know he wondered he said it
basically he went into a winning sex and
violence he got sex and violence and and
he got it in a way were made him go what
the hell is wrong with me like why did I
want to see that it delivered on what I
wanted to see but in such a realistic
way that it's like I just got here with
the reality that that's not a good thing
and what is wrong with me that I
actually was hoping to have a good time
watching that because I didn't have a
good time watching it
and it made him question the rest of
society as well you know and I think
that that movie a lot of the people who
I think actually liked the film did so
they did because they realized they
needed to change something about
themselves or their way of thinking and
the people a lot of people i think
didn't like it didn't like it for the
same reason you know and and then that
that's another thing too if people love
or hate something that's usually for the
same reason i think actually in a lot of
ways you know the people loved it and
hated it it's for the same reason either
they loved it because it you know spoke
of that issue or they hate it because it
spoke of that issue and that means that
it's the issue i guess not the film it's
the issue or is the subject which I'm
realizing knows I'm saying but you know
somebody that's it what would your
advice be to an 18 year old male or
female that's maybe gone through some of
the same things that you've gone through
and they feel really really alone but
they have this incredible creativity
that's inside of them probably from a
lot of the alone time but they want to
take these feelings that they have and
instead of doing some of the things that
we hear about that are so awful because
they feel this pain and authorities
aren't doing anything about it teachers
are blaming them and saying you're the
problem even though they're probably not
the problem but they've grown up their
entire lives believing that they are the
problem what would you tell someone like
that it has a lot of creativity and how
to channel it that's a lot um there's a
well some of these people have reached
out to me actually some of these execs
people that you're describing on with
with my name is a because you know what
it's about you know like it's it's
15 the 23 year old girls are really
which is not an audience I'm used to
having are really kind of latching on to
this movie even without heavy weather
they've figure out a way of seeing seen
it earlier or they haven't even seen it
and you know a lot of people have been
getting in contact with me because of it
through like Facebook and stuff and um
you know it's you know then they'll open
up right away you know some of these
people that I mean 11 girl I think yeah
I think she was a kid like 15 or
something she sent me pictures of her
self mutilated arm because she had seen
it wasn't my name is a but she saw the
self-harm video that YouTube band I'm
trying to remember what I told her it
was just I I told her basically because
that was one specific there I remember
because I was really not sure how to
handle it you know I was like I don't
know what to tell this girl and I just
really told her i just opened up about
myself and what i did and then um try to
let her know that you know i obviously
understand you because i'm an exact same
boat you know and maybe maybe sometimes
it's best not able to say that you used
to be there to say you Greg because I
currently still I'm always kind of there
so I'm because if you say oh I used to
be in the same sometimes that makes
people go oh but how did you get out you
know I think in some ways it almost
might be better to tell them I feel just
like you you know like I didn't used to
be in that place I still AM and that
might sound hopeless you know some
people who don't have these problems
might think oh that sounds hopeless but
I think to the people of do these
problems they if they see that you're
actually in the same boat but you're
you're in the same boat but you're
channeling it in other ways like you're
not you know self abusing or you're not
thinking of coin and killing somebody
you know that's that's why I thinking
I'm realizing this as I'm same as saying
it but that's why I think it's better to
not say I came out of it by doing this
because a lot of people just feel like
they can't come out of it say I
understand because I'm going through the
same thing and then they go oh you know
he's actually still dealing with it but
this is how he's dealing with it
you know i mean i think i think that
sounds more hopeful to them and it's the
truth you know why I'm always dealing
with these you know these issues or
they're always in the back of my mind or
whatever but as far as actual things
that they can do you know you can you
can if you if you want to make a movie I
mean you can be able to give a
smartphone because almost everybody even
homeless people I see have smartphones I
don't have put um most people have
smartphones I have a friend who shot a
whole movie on a smartphone and got an
actual distributor to put it out in
stores shoot it on your smartphone make
a video diary you know but with a
subject that's bothering you or doesn't
have to be that but if it could be
anything you know but if it helps if
it's your way of releasing your issues
it could be about your issues are
completely opposite you know but if it
makes you feel better about your issues
you know make a movie about it doing on
your smartphone you might actually be
able get a distributed or who knows you
might become the next YouTube sensation
and do it like as three-minute video
blogs you know right I just I've been
thinking about writing a book for years
and I just started writing a book that
opens with the thing that happened was
five that's the first chat brad is kind
of spit it out in like 15 minutes and um
and I just started that not even I was a
maybe was a week ago because I finally
saw a book written in a way where I
thought okay that's how I should write
it because I didn't I don't really read
I watched movies i read a lot of
information on read novels so i finally
saw a novel that was spelled out in a
way it was basically written like
memories and I thought okay that's how I
should write my novel so you even feel
like if you want to write but you don't
know how maybe look at how other people
have written because that's what
happened is I just really felt like I
can't get everything I want to stay out
on film and it's sorry to get people
together so even if I get a movie made I
still miss you 99 percent of what I want
to say how can I say everything I want
to say maybe be done with it I should
write a book but then I don't know how
to write a book you know on my
vocabulary's not even great but then I
you know we go to Barnes & Noble and I
start going through all kinds of books
and finally I found
like that's how I should write my book
and then then it was a matter of just
getting motivated or just you know
trying to figure out how to get all your
thoughts down and finally I'm like just
do it basically just do it finally I
just sat down and put the labs up down
last week and I'm like okay just do it
and I started writing then it was easy
because it's I think it's the hardest
thing is just putting the first finger
town you know but once you start doing
it just kind of flows out even shooting
it's like sometimes are not motivated to
shoot but then a second I hit record I
want to stop and there's so many thing
or you can volunteer if it's not a
creative you know volunteer and try and
help other people understand work at a
homeless shelter if you you know if it
depresses you like it can really depress
me like seeing people on the street like
I you know I'm a loner but I'll go and
hang out with homeless people all the
time you know if I get a good vibe from
them and they're not I don't think I'm
gonna get you know keep william i think
i'm going to get killed because it's
some kind of like a rush but i mean like
if i get a good vibe from homeless
people chat with them for three hours
you know even Keanu Reeves you could be
famous into it there's all this stuff
about Keanu Reeves um you know somebody
had been some paparazzi or spine on em
hang out some homeless guy names they're
like all day just hang out with the guy
you know I mean if a big celebrity can
do it you know and not worry about being
seen you know or what people think then
you can do that if that's another way of
channeling it and hopefully this all
makes sense but there's so many ways you
know volunteer if that helps write a
book if that helps shoot on your
smartphone if you don't have a camera
it's better than I mean I think the
quality might be better than some
cameras is better than the cameras I
used to shoot all damage reports are
killer stuff fun any smartphone is
better quality than that you know
there's so many things you can do and if
none of that helps
you know I don't know maybe just go
somewhere and scream until you have no
breath up I've even done that where it's
like and it comes out of nowhere and
that was something I did found recently
like six months ago where it's just like
you just start screaming and it's like
not screaming like you know pointlessly
I had to see me here in so much pain
that you just scream until you have no
voice left and you actually feel
relieved afterwards because you're like
you're exhausted from it it's kind of
like cutting yourself but better you
know because you're not harming yourself
like because cutting yourself the
problem is and people start doing this
when they start doing that they realize
it helps because it actually releases
like in natural endorphins in your body
and it actually is a natural high so the
problem with cutting yourself as it
actually does make you feel better so I
think a good way to maybe stop doing
that is like I said the screaming thing
I found out is it exhausts you and
that's kind of a cutting yourself does
you just kind of feel this high
afterwards and you feel how to feel
exhausted of that that negative energy
um but now you're harming yourself and
you'll want to do that so screaming I
think is actually and I've seen that in
a couple movies where people are so
starts out like coming of age movies and
somebody goes somewhere and it starts
screaming and that's when they like
finally feel better and and I recently
did that in real life when I was and
I've done it like three times now and
I'm like I almost lost complete control
of myself it's like it's like you're on
a drug but that's the point is somehow
it works and it works for a while you
don't feel good for just five minutes
like cutting yourself you can feel good
for a good week after that so maybe if
all else fails scream scream your
heart out you know